[Música]
[Aplausos]
en el trabajo como docente profesora
universitaria y consultora me he
dedicado al desarrollo de talento en
niños y jóvenes sobresalientes con un
enfoque en la diferenciación curricular
me he concentrado en formar líderes que
tengan una visión hacia el bien común
tanto en el ámbito local como global
originaria de la ciudad de mexico vivir
los efectos de la contaminación
ambiental en esa gran metrópolis y mi
deseo era algún día poder vivir en una
región llena de árboles a orillas de un
gran río un lugar que no estuviera sobre
poblando
hace más de una década me fui a vivir a
un pintoresco e histórico municipio en
norteamérica una localidad con ambiente
acogedor y seguro a unos cuantos minutos
de las cataratas que representan una de
las grandes maravillas del mundo
mi casa estaba ubicada cerca de un gran
río rodeada de árboles y numerosos
parques este lugar me hacía sentir
bienvenida
poco sabía yo que en esa región se
habían enterrado los desechos
radioactivos del proyecto manhattan el
cual dio origen a las primeras armas
nucleares durante la segunda guerra
mundial
al paso de los años es el material
radioactivo ha tenido efectos negativos
a nivel humano ecológico y económico en
la región el municipio además se
encuentra a unos cuantos kilómetros del
volcán al que se traduce como canal del
amor
se trata de un canal que fue planeado
para hacer el centro de una comunidad de
sueño sin embargo terminó convirtiéndose
en un basurero de desechos químicos
industriales que representan uno de los
desastres ambientales más serios de la
historia de la humanidad
aunque de una manera diferente a lo que
vivía en mi ciudad natal medio
nuevamente confrontando el problema
crónico de la contaminación un problema
relevante que está presente en muchas
regiones
pero que va en aumento en el mundo en
desarrollo se trata de una problemática
que interactúa con otros grandes
desafíos que enfrentamos como humanidad
entre esos desafíos está la mayor
frecuencia de catástrofes naturales la
cual tiene una relación con el cambio
climático las dificultades en el
suministro de agua potable en numerosas
regiones del planeta
o los incendios forestales las sequías
extremas las inundaciones
la desigualdad social creciente que está
extinguiendo a la clase media y otro
ejemplo muy relevante en este momento es
el comic 19
todos estos son desafíos que incorporan
elementos ecológicos económicos y de
equidad social que los líderes actuales
y futuros deben comprender a profundidad
los retos que estamos viviendo a nivel
internacional exigen una educación con
enfoque hacia la sostenibilidad que
permita a las nuevas generaciones no
sólo reaccionar sino sobre todo prevenir
situaciones que pongan en peligro la
integridad del entorno social y
ecológico
de eso depende nuestra sobrevivencia
como especie
cada uno de nosotros y cada evento que
vivimos es parte de un enorme
rompecabezas que va más allá de
fronteras geográficas o cronológicas
todo y todos somos parte de un entramado
de sistemas interconectados como la
familia la comunidad la nación y el
planeta
es decir los eventos que ocurren del
otro lado del planeta tienen un impacto
en nuestro país y en nuestras vidas
aunque sea de manera indirecta los
eventos del pasado influyen en nuestro
presente y nuestras acciones de hoy
tendrán consecuencias en las
generaciones venideras una educación
para la sostenibilidad requiere de la
comprensión holística de nuestro planeta
en tanto sistema el planeta tierra es la
única casa que hoy en día tenemos y
protegerla es proteger nuestra propia
existencia
la población actual se ha beneficiado de
numerosos avances científicos y
tecnológicos y de forma esta
organización social que ha permitido el
crecimiento económico en muchas regiones
sin embargo es difícil huir de los
efectos adversos que la
industrialización que inició en el siglo
18 ha tenido a largo plazo o de las
consecuencias desfavorables de ciertas
innovaciones por ejemplo en el ámbito
agrícola o de una serie de resultados no
previstos de la economía del libre
mercado
el enfoque antropocéntrico de los
últimos 10.000 años ha propiciado una
planeación a plazos relativamente cortos
es decir no se han contemplado las
implicaciones a muy largo plazo de las
acciones humanas
por ejemplo durante el siglo 18 y la
primera parte del siglo 19 existió un
gran énfasis en lograr una producción
industrial que redituará en beneficios
económicos inmediatos no hubo suficiente
previsión de las consecuencias a largo
plazo de esa producción no se tomaron
precauciones que limitarán la emisión de
gases de efecto invernadero que hoy
sabemos tienen un impacto en la
temperatura global como por ejemplo el
dióxido de carbono
la consecuencia actual de esta tendencia
humana es que nuestro planeta se
encuentra en una encrucijada de
problemas ecológicos humanos y
económicos muy complejos por ello
resulta imperativo que la educación para
las nuevas generaciones incorpore
elementos de sostenibilidad se trata de
unas en ciencia interdisciplinaria o
transdisciplinaria relativamente nueva
que incorpora el pensamiento de sistemas
al ser holístico este tipo de
pensamiento va más allá de las partes
individuales que pueden parecer
inconexas usando este pensamiento el
campo de la sostenibilidad enfatiza que
debemos satisfacer nuestras necesidades
actuales sin comprometer la capacidad de
futuras generaciones para satisfacer sus
propias necesidades
lo cual requiere de un equilibrio entre
el desarrollo económico el bienestar
social y la protección del planeta en
que vivimos
por muchos años el desarrollo económico
ha tenido predominancia hoy en día sin
embargo la humanidad está abriendo los
ojos a la realidad de que los aspectos
humanos sociales planetarios y
económicos deben ir de la mano por el
bien de todos
ahora bien la comprensión que cada uno
de nosotros tenga del medio que nos
rodea depende no solamente de nuestras
experiencias y conocimientos sino
también de nuestras creencias valores e
intereses los intereses que difieren
entre individuos y entre sociedades son
el lente a través del cual se observan
los problemas y los valores que están
detrás de esos intereses son
fundamentales porque determinan si la
persona analiza su mundo teniendo como
objetivo el bien común
el propósito de la educación para la
sostenibilidad es por un lado ayudar al
estudiante identificar y reflexionar
sobre su perfil individual de valores
intereses y creencias relacionados con
los diversos sistemas socioeconómicos y
ecológicos en los que vive y por otro
lado ayudarlos a adquirir y utilizar los
conocimientos interdisciplinarios que
les permitan tomar acciones específicas
que impacten su vida las diferencias
individuales en los perfiles y en las
necesidades educativas requieren de tres
tipos de diferenciación curricular
primero del contenido que se aprende
segundo del proceso a través del cual se
aprende y tercero de la
individualización de los productos que
resultan de ese aprendizaje por ejemplo
en el ámbito del acceso al agua potable
la función del sistema cutzamala en el
abastecimiento de la ciudad
representará un contenido muy distinto
al de la función de la bahía de hudson
en el sistema hidrológico de canadá
además el proceso a través del cual se
aprende este contenido debe adaptarse
para ser relevante a las circunstancias
del estudiante
no es lo mismo entender el sistema
hídrico que lleva al besar este
desabastecimiento de agua en la alcaldía
vista palapa y sus consecuencias
sociopolíticas que las circunstancias
más benéficas que existen en otros en
otras alcaldías en este proceso de
aprendizaje
es importante entender de manera crítica
como actos dañinos al sistema ecológico
derivan en opresión hacia seres humanos
concretos en situaciones específicas
esto requiere de un enfoque transversal
o interdisciplinario de los problemas
por ejemplo las inequidades en el acceso
al agua potable pueden ser estudiadas
desde la intersección de las ciencias
naturales las ciencias sociales y las
humanidades
en cuanto al producto del aprendizaje en
el ámbito de la sostenibilidad es
importante usar el contexto local en la
diferenciación curricular esto ayuda a
los estudiantes por ejemplo a entender
las injusticias socio ecológicas que
existen en su entorno sin embargo
también deben incorporarse elementos
globales que den un panorama general por
ejemplo un plan elaborado por
estudiantes para mejorar mejorar el
abastecimiento de agua la ciudad de
méxico tendría que considerar
problemáticas globales como el cambio
climático ya que lo que ocurre en una
región del país no representa una
dinámica aislada sino parte de procesos
amplios a nivel planetario
el preparar líderes capaces de enfrentar
los problemas complejos del mundo real
exige ir más allá de una formación en
disciplinas aisladas es imperativo que
quienes somos educadores o profesores en
diversas asignaturas trabajemos de
manera colaborativa para elaborar un
currículum transversal o
interdisciplinario que tenga un enfoque
amplio de lo que significa ser ciudadano
generalmente el concepto de ciudadanía
nos hace pensar en acciones no obstante
si contemplamos el hecho de que nuestro
planeta es un sistema en el cual todos
estamos interrelacionados y hacia el
cual todos tenemos responsabilidades
entonces surge la noción de ciudadanía
planetaria como ciudadanos del planeta
es urgente y necesario que tengamos una
educación en sostenibilidad que
incorpore elementos de diversas áreas
del saber y así podamos crear una
sociedad justa y equitativa que esté en
balance con su entorno ecológico
el aprendizaje de contenidos científicos
es insuficiente es imperativo que
definamos como educadores y como
educandos nuestros valores creencias y
actitudes con respecto a los grandes
desafíos que enfrenta la humanidad
en tanto individuos debemos identificar
nuestro papel ante estos grandes grandes
desafíos y ante nuestra lucha por el
bien común
el espíritu creativo humano no solamente
ha producido innovaciones que tienen
consecuencias negativas inesperadas sino
que es y será el origen de las de las
soluciones a los grandes problemas que
enfrenta la humanidad estas soluciones
requerirán de la creación de visiones
globales y a más largo plazo en un
ámbito de colaboración
en el 2018 cuando la criticada y
elogiada joven activista sueca greta
thunberg
inició el movimiento viernes por un
futuro entre ti porque lo hacía y cuando
mi hijo menor participó en esos bienes
entonces realmente vendí porque lo hacía
estamos viviendo en una época de cambio
de paradigma en el que la educación
asumirá un papel fundamental nuestra
generación tiene en sus manos el poder
de cambiar la historia a fin de crear un
mundo sano y justo para todas las
regiones del mundo y para las
generaciones venideras
en este camino hacia el bien común las
acciones de cada individuo cuentan la
decisión de crear un mundo sustentable
es nuestra
es tu decisión
[Aplausos]